[music]
>> Expectation number three.
Able to speak the truth Allah
in front of public without hesitation.
And this is very important.
That speaking the truth
in front of public without hesitation
only Allah can make it possible.
But when you are dying, there bound to
be difficulties that come in your way.
And the more effective you are, the more
difficulty will come.
The less effective you are, the less
The moment you start being effective
Allah also wants to test you.
That he made you effective.
Do you shy away when you find something
difficult?
The more effective you are
the more difficulties will come to you.
And the more difficult will be your
test. If Allah wants to give you
a higher grade in Jannah, then the test
he will give you is also more difficult.
That is the reason beloved prophet
Muhammad said the tests given to
Ambiya's
the messengers, the prophets were
multiple times more than the normal
human being.
Because the messengers are on a higher
platform
than the normal human beings.
So but naturally the test also should be
high.
All the Ambiya's 100% underwent more
difficulties than any other human being
in the world.
Hadith of Muhammad we say the times are
very bad. What difficulty we face, no
one in the ummah has faced.
In the full Muslim ummah. You know
because they don't know their deen.
When Allah Ta'ala according to the
Hadith of Muhammad said
says that the tests put on the Ambiya's
are more than the human beings. We think
that we are in a difficult situation.
But comparatively and logically they
were in a situation multiple times more
difficult than us.
And the turmoil that they went through,
if you compare,
our life is luxury.
It's real luxury. So, if you know the
seerah of the prophet and the seerah of
the sahaba,
you'll realize that what Allah has
blessed us with
is mashallah.
People are afraid
to identify themselves as Muslims today.
Afraid to keep beard, afraid to wear a
cap, afraid to identify that they're
Muslims because of the time that we are
in. Oh, this is a very difficult time.
Never in the history of Islam. They
don't know the history of Islam.
Yes.
You may find certain difficulties
compared to what difficulties the
earlier people in the ummah had, ours is
negligible. May Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala make us to pass this test
and may accept our efforts, inshallah.
But, that's a very important point. That
speak the truth
in front of the public without
hesitation, inshallah. But,
one more thing. If Allah has given you
the skills of public speaking,
Allah says in the Quran in Surah Nisa,
chapter number four, verse number 135,
that stand out for justice as witness
for Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala,
even if it be against yourself,
against your parents, against your
relatives,
>> [snorts]
>> irrespective whether they're rich or
poor, for Allah protects both.
So, Allah says
that as far as justice is concerned,
it's the duty of a moment. It's the duty
of a Muslim that he should stand firmly
as witness to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
for truth, even if it be against
yourself.
Many a time when people realize that if
we speak the truth, we may have problems
in our lives, and they're afraid to
speak the truth. So, if Allah has given
you the power of speaking, and if you
abstain from speaking the truth, Allah
will take away that power.
All your dawa training program would be
in the drain.
So, may this expectation be fulfilled
that he gives to the die
to speak the truth with hikma.
With hikma is very important.
And what is hikma we will deal
in the time to come inshallah.
Point number four, continuing the dawa
spirit of Dr. Zakir Naik who
successfully inspires millions of
people. Inshallah. That is one of the
objectives of the training program.
That may Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
create more dies
so that you get sawab and through you
inshallah even I get some sawab. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala does not divide the
sawab, he multiplies it.
And other thing 100 point is that you
get 50, you get 50. Allah says, "No, 100
points. You get 100, you get 100. No
problem."
So, when sawab is multiplied without
decreasing your sawab
or without decreasing my sawab.
So, we pray to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
that may accept our efforts. Point
number five, protecting Islam from the
lost people who fail to explain Islam in
such liberal ways.
I know what the intention is. But
protecting Islam from lost people who
fail to explain Islam in such liberal
ways.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala does not
require any of us to protect Islam.
Point to be noted, no one can harm
Islam.
If all the world put together.
Yes, you can say image of Islam, no
problem.
So, many a time we say things
with the correct intention, it may mean
otherwise.
If you say I want to protect the image
of Islam, fine.
You can damage the image of Islam, but
no one can damage Islam. Allah
is there enough to protect it.
Allah promises in the Quran
in no less than three different places.
In Surah Taubah, chapter number nine,
verse number 33. In Surah Fatah, chapter
number 48, verse 28. And Surah Saff,
chapter number 16, verse number nine.
Allah says, "Huwa alladhi arsala
rasulahu bil huda wa din al-haqq
liyuzhirahu ala ad-dini kullihi walau
kariha al-mushrikun."
That Allah sent his messenger with
guidance and the religion of truth so
that it prevail over all the other
religions, over all the other isms,
whether they be Christianity, Judaism,
Buddhism, Hinduism, atheism. Islam is
destined to supersede all of them.
Master them all.
However, the mushriks don't like it.
Allah does not require you and me the
rubbish that we are.
If I start thinking that if I don't do
dawa, Islam will not spread, I'm the
biggest fool in the world.
Allah has promised this deen will
prevail.
Allah does not require you and me the
rubbish that we are.
Allah himself is sufficient to make his
deen prevail. He is giving us an
opportunity to do a prophet's job and to
earn a prophet's reward.
Allah does not require If I start
thinking if Peace TV is not there, Islam
will not spread or Zakir Naik is not
there, I'm the biggest fool in the
world.
Allah can create a million Peace TV
within a fraction of a second, can
create million Zakir Naik within a
fraction of a second. He is giving us an
opportunity
to make hay while the sun is shining.
He's giving us an opportunity.
He alone is sufficient.
So, please a daee should be aware that
if he gets success,
you thank Allah.
Why do you thank Allah?
He is utilizing
our services which he does not require.
He utilizes our service which he doesn't
require.
He alone is sufficient.
He is giving an opportunity to do a
prophet's job and to earn a prophet's
reward. So, you can say to correct the
image of Islam
or to remove the misconceptions of
Islam, Islam per se
does not require our help at all.
You may help Muslims.
So, when you use terminology, a die, you
should be aware.
Then your faith increases more.
No one can damage Islam.
It is the best dean.
It will remain the best.
Allah says in Surah Al Imran, chapter 3,
verse 19.
And Surah Al Imran, chapter 3, verse 35,
that
in the dean of Allah is Islam. Surah Al
Imran, chapter 3, verse 19. 85 says that
no other religion will be acceptable in
the sight of Allah except Islam.
So, may Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
utilize
our services
to make his dean prevail. He doesn't
require that.
Point number six, having the priceless
knowledge, sharing and meeting different
Muslim people from different parts of
the world. If you could say that
sharing with dies of different parts of
the world, that expectation is better
than Muslims. Muslims in different parts
of the world you can meet in many other
places. Maybe better
variety. We have only 10 countries.
And the seventh one is being closer to
Allah, the almighty, and he is the best
protector in this world and the
hereafter, inshallah. May this training
program bring you closer to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala, and may Allah
fulfill all your correct intentions
and your expectations, inshallah.
We have got one, two, three participants
left.
The third last is Dr. Rehman Yunus.
>> [snorts]
>> His first expectation is to gain the
sahih authentic knowledge of Islam
and present the right picture of Islam.
Inshallah.
Number two,
to learn how to have discussions
with non-Muslims regarding Islam,
including icebreakers.
Yes, we'll be dealing with that,
inshallah.
Point number three,
should be able to convince non-Muslims
that Islam is the truth and remove the
misconceptions.
Inshallah, with Allah's help.
Point number four, if I'm asked
questions regarding Islam, then I want
to give appropriate answers relating to
the topic. And moreover, the important
point is convincing them.
That's a very important point. Giving
answers is easy.
Giving convincing answers is difficult.
Giving answers is very easy.
But giving convincing answers is the
challenge.
So, that's what we pay attention on
during question answer session.
That you should try and convince
the opposite person.
Expectation number five, to learn the
methods of Dawah from the expert in the
field by the man himself, Dr. Zakir
Naik.
May Allah make it possible that I can
share some of my experiences, inshallah.
And as I told you that I'm a student,
may Allah accept that effort.
Point number six,
I'll be living in China for eight more
months and majority of the people whom I
have spoken
with are atheists. So, I want to master
in convincing the atheists.
I have rarely met any Chinese Buddhist.
Chinese where I live, eight upon 10 I
asked, they were atheists.
Yes, I do agree with you. I've been to
China once.
And I'm aware that the Chinese don't
allow propagation.
Knowing that very well, I did give
certain lectures, a few lectures
in China when I was there in 2014, about
1 year 2 months back.
And all the lectures were without
publicity.
And
I gave in various cities,
including Qichao, Inchuan, Beijing,
Shanghai.
With announcement of maybe in the
Maghrib salah I'm going to give a talk
in the Isha salah. And by Allah's grace,
the audience was
comparatively large. In a 1-hour notice,
1,000 people coming is big.
And I remember when I was in Beijing,
the second last day,
the police came and knocked at my door.
And they said, "Dr. Zakir, we know
you're a speaker. Do you want any car?
Do you want to extend your visa? etc.
etc.?
I said, "No, I have a visa which is yet
for 2 weeks and I'm leaving tomorrow."
Indirectly, they came and told me,
"Don't give lectures."
I know that very well
that propagation
in public in China is not allowed. But
alhamdulillah, Allah gave an
opportunity. I don't know whether I'll
go to China again or not.
I took the risk and it was
>> [snorts]
>> masha Allah, worth it. And personally,
I had the opportunity to speak to
only five Chinese one-to-one.
And alhamdulillah,
all five of them accepted Islam.
Alhamdulillah.
Normally,
there was a time I remember in my old
days where I used to love speaking
one-to-one.
That was my passion.
I remember
when I had just started,
if I came to know one non-Muslim is
there, I used to go on my bike full
speed. I can't miss it.
And we used to go and we used to speak,
alhamdulillah. Now, the times have
changed.
People want to speak in front of the
time. We are more on the
different level. Not that I don't like I
love it.
But as the Sharia says, let a small loss
take place to prevent a big loss, we are
targeting the bigger non-Muslim on the
satellite thing.
So, we are more becoming a wholesaler
rather than retailers. But this is a
retail workshop.
This is retail. Retail means
small. But indirectly, also wholesale.
That's the satellite.
So, I do agree with you that though they
claim that they would be the majority of
them atheist. And we'll be having one
day exclusively for atheists, insha
Allah.
Point number seven, the last one. Last
but not the least, I'll be having
one-to-one discussion type of
conversation rather than lecture time.
So, I want to learn some icebreakers and
keys to overcome this kind of situation.
Insha Allah, we'll be dealing with that
tomorrow to a small extent and during
the course of the time, insha Allah.
May Allah fulfill all the correct
expectations that you have
and may Allah make it possible.
>> [music]
[music]
[singing]